hi i'm rich let's submit a table for the
2022 table contest let's assume you've
created the table that you want to share
that's the table contests and viewpoint
we need to fill out a few things to get
your table submitted so let's do that
table title
usernames you have to have an rstudio
username to even submit just enter it
here remember to use the add sign just
before your username i put mine in
great authors include all authors if you
can right here just comma separate them
social links if you're on twitter
anywhere else social
put in your links right here you can use
markdown styling for these links
we'll give special recognition to folks
who are newer to data science people
that are new
less than one year or more i am
definitely more in one year so i chose
that but if you are new choose less than
one year
submission type
uh there's four
there's a single table example that's
what i have right here it's one table i
just want to show everything i can in
this one table
uh if you have something that's really
long have lots of text and you're
teaching people that is most definitely
a tutorial for other if your submission
doesn't fit into the single table
example or tutorial category select
other we're recognizing this year if
your table is built with r and or python
so you may have a scenario where you're
getting the data all sort of like
through python you're making the table
with r
or maybe doing the reverse who knows
maybe you're just doing it all in python
whatever to choose but the checkbox is
here what languages you used
libraries packages
you need to use them to make tables for
this table example i just used gt so
i'll put it there you may use a bunch of
these
packages you may just use one choose the
one that you used
for your example
category
so there's four of these uh static html
one table it's html table
interactive so your html table has
things that you can sort of click on you
can filter do all sorts of like really
fancy things which are interactive
that's what that's for
static print that is more or less things
like latex things which are you know
like word documents you're just writing
tables to like some pages
they're not html at all
interactive shiny that is most
definitely html and you're basically
using shiny in that case a table inside
shiny
so that's the category
short description here we have two
fields for a short and long description
short and full we're calling them
just choose a something that's short for
the short description obviously tweet
length give give like just a good round
up of what your table is trying to do uh
what you used what inspired you all
sorts of things like that just keep it
short uh for full description you can go
wild and just like tell everything about
tell us everything that you
uh considered what technologies you used
just fully flesh it out in full
description and again you don't have to
completely everything perfect in this
form
this can be edited afterwards industries
if this table pertains to some
particular industry like life science
finance public sector what have you just
mentioned here you know we want to know
if you know if this table pertains to a
field like that
we care about that sort of thing
called apostrophe a lot of times you'll
have your uh table code and a github
repo
i linked to one repo here it doesn't
really exist but it's a repo nonetheless
that could exist make sure you put your
table code in a repo
and share the link right here in this
field
for a link to the table we prefer that
you use quota pub
i have it right here this is my table
entry in quarto pub we can share right
out of quarter pub by hitting this share
button and then copy link
and that's what i did here i just copied
it straight into here
like so you may be you know creating a
shiny table uh sorry a shiny app with a
table inside of it so you might be using
shiny apps and we accept other forms too
but you know try to use quartal pub if
you can't our studio cloud project
you may opt to use our studio cloud to
host your
your table code in
it's a great option for you know when
you want people who want to share the
table
and you want people to interactively get
in there and you know play with your
code
i actually already have a cloud project
set up with this table in it i can grab
the link right here in the browser
and i can put it right here so basically
it's going to look like this rco.cloud
content and some number which is your
project
and that is it
then you just got to hit the done button
and what it does is it takes you
do something like this it's like
right before you actually create the
topic itself
so basically all the stuff that was in
the form populates inside here it's
great
you really don't want to touch it at all
you just want to create the topic so
let's hit this
button and soon you'll get your entry
and this is actually live this is
actually a posted topic
on our studio community here where you
can edit your uh submission
just right here and then yeah you can go
in here and go to the full description
you know add things like images to your
description you can add you know change
the text totally up to you you can save
the edit or you can cancel out of it
you know the option is there once you
have it in here uh your submission is
entered and
yeah i hope you win
and that's it i hope to see you in this
year's table contest if you're looking
for ideas we encourage you to check out
the table gallery and to participate in
the weekly tidy tuesday on twitter